what's up elimination I am coming to
Philadelphia and Palm Springs on May 7th
and May 8th and want to meet up with you
alright so I'm doing a little bit of
travel in May I'm going to Philadelphia
to hang out with Satguru at one of his
events in her engineering then I'm
heading to Palm Springs California for
an event called clammer con which is a
big event for youtubers had a lot of fun
last year I'll be vlogging it hopefully
meet some of you guys there and one of
the things that I love doing when I
travel is to meet you it's one of my
favorite things to do I love
understanding your businesses I love
connecting I love answering questions I
love signing books whatever I'm not I'm
not there to promote or sell anything I
just want to understand who's watching
the channel get to know my fans and have
some fun it's always been a really
really good time and again whenever I
travel I try to think with you guys as
much as possible so for those of you who
are in the Philadelphia area May 7th I'm
gonna be there all day long one of our
fans Michael has booked off a we work
location for us to meet at 10 o'clock so
from 10 a.m. to noon we're gonna meet
there and then I've got the rest of the
day pretty much open before I fly out
the morning of the 8th so if you guys
have some ideas you want to do something
there's something I must see maybe go
salsa day is saying I don't know let me
know hit me up the best way to do it is
we have a Facebook page there's an event
there you can go say you're coming you
can give suggestions in the feedback on
that page so go check that out we have
the link in the description and I'm
really looking forward to meeting some
of you there
timo what you're doing timo wants to say
hi I said hi let me say hi you're not
coming to fill it off yet we're Palm
Springs mister you got to stay here you
can about yourself
well Nina's gonna be with you but you
won't have me all right back to the show
Palm Springs I don't know how many of
you guys are in Palm Springs I had one
person reach out to me an email saying
she wanted to connect and have some
lunch there so I fly in on the 8th in
the Palm Springs I think I get there
around 12:30 something like that I
haven't created a Facebook event I don't
know if I'm going to do a formal thing
or not if there's enough of you who want
to meet up in Palm Springs on the 8th it
has to be in the afternoon because I fly
in again the land at 12:30 something
like that and then I have
an event that evening and then after
that I'm completely booked off on on the
climber con event stuff so if you have
space if you're in Palm Springs the
afternoon of the 8th and you want to
connect and do something leave it in the
comments of this video and I'll check in
and if there's enough people then then I
might do a Facebook event on it as well
so hopefully I'll get to meet some you
guys there for everybody else maybe I'll
come to your city it's one of the things
I love doing the most if you've ever had
a question for me or you just want to
stop by and say hi you want to meet some
other fellow members of belief nation in
your city please come out it's always a
great time if you're nervous don't be
it's super fun I want to take some
selfies I want to answer questions and
really just get to know you and help you
in your business that's it guys thank
you so much I look forward to meeting
you continue to believe and whatever
your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details